it's always important when you're doing
stories on education to reflect that
things are going to be different in
different parts of the United Kingdom
what's happening in Wales and how
worried are you about children being out
of the classroom for so long well as
from tomorrow all schools across Wales
our van in Anglesey where we have a
local outbreak of coronavirus will go
back or children will have an
opportunity to check in to catch up and
to prepare for the summer and into the
autumn and we are very keen indeed to do
that because of our anxieties about
vulnerable children about children who
are moving from primary to secondary
school and of course in Wales we have
large numbers of children who are taught
through the medium of Welsh but who may
not hear that much Welsh at home it's
interesting isn't because you're
obviously taking the view that you're
trying to get all schools back into the
classroom children's right back into the
classroom at least for limited periods
rotating the children in school each day
it goes against some of the advice
that's given from the UK government
saying that teachers should try and
stick to one group of students where
possible to avoid being overexposed do
you worried that it could be putting
teachers at risk by this plan no we
worked very hard indeed with our trade
union colleagues and our local education
authorities they had more than three
weeks notice of our intention to reopen
schools and a huge effort has gone on by
teachings teachers and non teaching
staff to make sure that schools will be
safe safe for teachers say for students
I know hundreds of conversations across
Wales between parents and head teachers
looking to see what has been put in
place we are confident that we can do
this safely and we are confident that we
are doing the right thing for the
benefit of children it was really
interesting going to talk to the head
teacher at the school in Crawley this
week he was saying that new teachers can
do everything they can to reach out to
children they know a vulnerable but of
course if some are disengaged from
education it might be very difficult to
get them to re-engage unless they get
back in the classroom what kind of in
do you think it you will see on these
children if they are away from the
classroom so long well one of the
reasons why we working to reopen all
schools is that we've learned something
from the last three months we've had 450
schools in Wales open throughout the
pandemic for vulnerable children and
children of key workers what we're
finding is is that if you're a
vulnerable child and your school is open
you tend to go there but if you're asked
to go to a different school where
teachers you may not know when children
you may not be familiar with a journey
or not used to making then you tend not
to go there so by reopening all schools
we think we have a real chance to make
sure that those children we are most
concerned about come back to the school
door and then we will be able to have
that face-to-face contact with them talk
to their parents make a plan not all
children are in the position of having
all the resources they need at home and
our efforts are really concentrated on
making sure that we reach those we need
to reach the most and by opening all
schools we think that's a really
significant way in which we can make
that happen it's very interesting
observation actually you can see why
parents can be concerned about you know
their children particularly younger
children re settling in a new
environment in times already you know
very different to normality for them now
in England pubs restaurants and similar
venues it can be reopening from the
fourth of July what's happening in Wales
and do you think that Boris Johnson is
moving too quickly well we are planning
with our hospitality sector to see if we
can safely reopen outdoor hospitality
here in Wales either series are very
good conversations with the sector last
week and we hope to conclude those
conversations of the first half of next
week but we will continue to do things
in the way we've done things in Wales
carefully cautiously one step at a time
we put our efforts into planning first
and making the announcement second not
making an announcement and then thinking
about how you can make those things
happen
so do you think that's what the UK
government the Boris Johnson their
government's been doing well my concerns
with the UK government are sometimes
less with the substance where I think we
are all broadly still trying to do the
same things I'm more concerned at the
messaging the way things are described
here in Wales I am very keen to continue
to say to Welsh citizens coronavirus has
not gone away it remains something that
kills people in Wales every day if you
don't stay on top of it you will see
things going backwards and everything
that we have done together thrown away
and that's a very different message I
think to the message across the border
where the message seems much more that
you know it's all over and you can go
back to doing everything as you did
before I think we're seeing around the
world how that leads to flare-ups of the
disease again so in substance I don't
think we're that far apart we give a
much more sober message to people in
Wales because we are still in a
coronavirus crisis interesting to hear
about your concerns and the messaging do
you think the Prime Minister is perhaps
too keen to give good news well you know
it's not for me to tell other people how
they should make decisions elsewhere as
I say ëwell here in Wales we have had
enormous social solidarity from people
in sticking to the 2-meter rule in doing
the right things I don't want them to
hear a message that some simply says
it's all over there is going to be
freedom Saturday where you can do as you
like
you can't not if you want to be careful
about your own health and the health of
other people this crisis is not over
it's not over in Wales and it's not over
across the whole of the United Kingdom
and that's what we need to be reminding
people of as we move together to restore
freedoms to people where we are
confident we have the Headroom to do so
I just want to look at some of your
track record on white Wales as well
particularly on testing now we know of
course how important testing is as we
ease our way out of lockdown and trying
to stop any flare-ups of the virus in
the future
something whales have struggled with
frankly no you set in a drop to target
if 5,000 tests a day in April last month
the Welsh secretary said that Wells had
fallen behind the other three nations on
testing and it was making progress with
this whole recovery process so much
slower what is happening with testing in
Wales and have you really got a grip on
the situation no I think we are
absolutely on top of testing here in
Wales we have thousands more tests
available in Wales today than we did
earlier in the disease we have
demonstrated this week where we've had
two major outbreaks in north west and
north east Wales but our test race for
tech system has worked very effectively
where we've been on top of those
outbreaks very quickly where we
mobilized mass testing where the results
are back within 24 hours where we
believe we are able to contain the
outbreaks so we don't yet see community
spread from them we may have had to
build up our system more slowly but I
think our system is now in very good
shape
and demonstrating every day but it is
working effectively